grand moment pour ces élèves de seconde
et de terminale du lycée descartes de
voisins-le-bretonneux le lancement de
leur ballon sonde ils ont travaillé tous
les mercredis après midis depuis près
d'un an qu'on a avec les élèves conçu
une nacelle dans laquelle on a mis
plusieurs séries de capteurs et puis des
caméras grâce à l'enthousiasmé de leur
professeur de physique chimie
une dizaine d'élèves a imaginé des
expériences calcul de pression de
température mesure d'ozone qu'on a fait
la nacelle on a testé les déposants on a
discuté de tout ce qui allait se passer
à travers le projet une spécialiste des
balles on va les aider à effectuer le
décollage les autorisations nécessaires
auprès de la mairie de l'aviation civile
ont été obtenues tout est planifié
certains s'occupent du gonflage de tenir
le ballon d'autres de l'assemblage final
une check list comme pour une fusée ça
c'est la fiche de vol et signal
il n'y a pas de croix on n'en voit pas
tout est prêt le vol doit durer trois
heures
moment d'émotion et de joie pour tous à
certains qu'à voir ce ballon s'envoler
dans les airs c'est magique chauffe
après avoir atteint la stratosphère à
près de 26 mille mètres d'altitude
le ballon a explosé et la nacelle est
descendu freiné par son parachute
atterrissage réussi à une cinquantaine
de kilomètres la nacelle est retrouvée
grâce aux radios amateurs qui suivait le
trajet en temps réel la nacelle est
intacte toutes les données de vol vont
pouvoir être récupérés et analysés une
grande expérience pour ces lycéens et
leurs professeurs